severe weather is a threat today from
South Carolina to New Jersey and in the
northwest in the Northeast it's still
call that flood watches and warnings are
in effect mark Strassmann is in Weston
Georgia were reported twister tore
through several buildings mark good
morning good morning when the manager of
this agricultural store heard bad
weather was heading this way he sent
home all of his employees just in case a
good thing because 90 minutes later the
storm was here and this is what the
business look like our twister ripped
through this rural area and whatever it
hit it hit with punishing power big
tornado big big tornado tornadoes hail
flash floods and high winds caused
damage from the deep south to the
Midwest on Wednesday at least nine
reported twisters touchdown one
destroying several buildings in south
Georgia the top on the home house
thought about peeling off so we knew it
was a rare serious thorn high winds
toppled trees and crushed this pickup
truck and a mobile home it could be much
worse I'm very thankful that it's not
hailstones some as large as baseball's
founded neighborhoods even peeling the
paint off homes along Atlanta's
Peachtree Creek this truck became
trapped in rising floodwaters five city
workers were stranded and first
responders use rafts to rescue them
drenching rains caused flash flooding
near columbia south carolina lightning
struck across the region and is believed
to be responsible for starting several
house fires everything I've know I was
damaged in it I said almost thinking
salvage anything at the masters golf
tournament in Augusta the severe weather
caused the cancellation of Wednesday's
par 3 contest for the first time ever
and forced hundreds of people to leave
two people were hurt but no one was
killed by these storms but the impact
was felt north at atlanta's airport
where hundreds of travelers stranded
travelers had to spend the night the
local forecast is clear the rest of this
week good news for the Masters
Tournament at a gun
to Georgia for all the players and all
the fans watching them compete Nora
absolutely mark thank you so much